il ya une rue le corbusier à pessac
c'est parce qu'il ya eu henry frugès
frugès industriel bien connu dans le
secteur sucrier peintres architectes
musiciens homme de grande culture au
début du siècle il fit appel à le
corbusier pour construire des maisons
selon ses plans
voici ce qu'il en reste or la mairie de
pessac propriétaire d'un de ces
immeubles veut montrer l'exemple
elle l'a restauré et remis à l'état
d'origine
il sera très bientôt un musée à la
mémoire d'henri frugès cette cité est
connu dans le monde entier car elle fut
un des premiers ensembles architecturaux
alliés les techniques du béton armé ou
cellules pré fabriqué ces structures
bénéficié à l'époque d'un ensoleillement
important par la création de larges
baies vitrées d'un chauffage individuel
air pulsé d'eau courante électricité
sanitaires
trois types de maisons existent tels
qu'henri frugès les voulait quinconces
gratte-ciel zigzag
cet homme était très en avance sur son
temps il provoqué bien des sourires
moqueurs
cette maison de la ville de pessac et le
symbole aujourd'hui d'une renaissance
pourquoi pas suivi par d'autres ce
serait un très bel hommage à fruges s